[Musique]
le
la maltraitance infantile la douleur
sous toutes ses formes en plus de
laisser des traces psychologiques et
affective
cette violence modifie de façon
permanente la structure du cerveau de
l'enfant
[Musique]
on sait aujourd'hui quelles zones sont
directement affectés cette découverte
remonte à l'an 2000
il y a 20 ans l'enfant maltraité
lorsqu'il deviendra adulte devra
affronter de multiples défis
cette enfance passée sous le règne de la
violence le rendra plus à risque de
développer de l'anxiété de consommer des
drogues ou de se suicider
[Musique]
en 2000 des chercheurs américains de
l'université ravens aux états unis
découvrent et identifie quatre types de
lésions cérébrales liées à la
maltraitance
le système limbique est un réseau de
neurones parfois appelée cerveau
émotionnel
ils contrôlent bon nombre de nos
émotions et notre instinct de survie
[Musique]
les abus qu'ils soient physiques
psychologiques ou sexuelles perturbe les
impulsions électriques qui permettent la
communication de ces cellules
l'hémisphère gauche celui qui contrôle
le langage serait moins bien développer
chez l'enfant maltraité l'hémisphère
droit compenserait en étant plus actifs
et en sueur exprimant des émotions
négatives
[Musique]
le corps calleux relie les deux
hémisphères du cerveau chez l'enfant
maltraité le corps calleux est plus
petit
suffisamment pour entraîner des
changements d'humeur et personnalités le
vernis du cervelet est une partie du
cerveau impliquées dans les émotions et
la tension le patient maltraités semble
avoir un vernis du cervelet plus actifs
affectant du même coup son équilibre
émotionnel
dans ses conclusions l'équipe de rolf
hug pense que le stress causé par le
mans traitance libère certaines hormones
et neurotransmetteur tout en en inhibant
d'autres
cette activité chimique remodèle le
cerveau afin que la personne puisse
mieux ressentir la peur l'anxiété et le
stress pour se protéger